ja am besten ist sie dreht sich doch mal
ein bisschen und immer die hosen runter
war ich muss mir das jetzt schon genau
anschauen
leute ich fasse es nicht ohne scheiß
dich traf es nicht ich weiß nicht was
abgeht das ist so eine story das kann
man sich nicht ausdenken mir fragt euch
was gedacht ja der kampf gegen platz
eins der youtube fans geht in eine neue
runde leute werden von zwei videos
dieser art gemacht wir haben gemacht
sein dass wir uns eine fake waffe dann
frank groß und der fake schatz und jetzt
ist auch das einst in den youtube trends
schon wieder so ein video man sich
einfach denkt mensch nicht abgeschlossen
das video stammt von dem kanal hilfen
hier juncker und verzweifelt und heißt
ein hintern die kampage anteil träumt
vom double butt das kann ja in der
scheiße werden platz einzel trends leute
für genau dieses video
[Musik]
was machst du willst natürlich könnte
ich dieses video jetzt zu beenden
aber dort läuft es beim thema bleiben
kann teilt räumt natürlich vom bovert
das ist ihr großer traum und sie trägt
auch das öfteren in ihrem zimmer
hast du das nötig warum mama zum zweiten
halt wir kennen also endlich diese
unterhaltung mit unserer mutter wir sind
in unserem zimmer chillen hören nicki
minaj oder kgb und torten uns die seele
aus dem leib die mutter kommt rein und
verstehen einfach nicht dass es unser
größtes bedürfnis ist tief in unserer
serie einfach auszudrücken
also da kann ich noch gar nicht mit
meinem richtigen
bis jetzt hat er mich immer nur kurz
gesehen würde so kommentiert worden über
qualität so ein bisschen im beauty waren
alle wollen kim kardashian und anderen
stars mit großen hinter nacheifern wozu
eigentlich kim kardashian gibt es schon
reichen wenn die den hintern hat klasse
wäre wenn chantal sagen könnte ich vorm
spiegel gar nicht so schlecht dass
schüler aber wirklich also ganz kurz ein
ernstes heute in diesem video wo kein
letztes mal sagen wir einfach ein
problem so
körper ideal die von so häufig im kader
stehen und kann also vorgegeben werden
dann kamen durch viele mädels probleme
weil diese nach zwangspausen operiert
und dann wollen sie so sein und es geht
halt nicht das schmalz business dabei
aber haben wir mal ich will gehen dann
von großen massen mit der ganzen ikone
sitzen lassen und denkt sich nur
einfach perfekt und du hast perfekten
rostigen nagel mir da christel von mir
keine unterstützung sagte jetzt schon
ein unter aller sau so geht das nicht
ich finde wenn ein teenager mädchen in
deutschland das bedürfnis hat sich
wassermelonen ins gesäß rein operieren
zu lassen dann muss die mutter das
bezahlen
aber wir nehmen das jetzt mal bewachen
müssen
okay ganz klar die positiven satz wie
man so zu seiner freundin sagen würde
wenn die gerade reinkommt jungs schatz
was geht nichts mit chicken gerade
einfach nur draußen gesehen hatten
[Musik]
verpiss dich doch das war mir einfach
die beste option schon toll chantal ist
immer noch entschlossen sich implantate
in den po einsetzen zu lassen
warum dieser typ ist möglich und ich
sagen muss ich sagen
den gurken auf den augen da brauchen sie
sich nicht entschuldigen mich
interessiert das sehr wohl wenn ich mich
kurz vorstellen darf dr anton lieber ich
bin der schönheitschirurg hier
vielleicht ja das kann ich so nicht
sagen da muss ich schon mal sehen um was
es sich hier handeln
damit ich mir das mal also der nächste
tag chantal braucht die kopie um jeden
preis in ihrer not zweifel die 18
jährige nicht an der seriosität des
schönheitschirurgen wir kurzfristig
einen hausbesuch zugestimmt hat aber ich
muss mir das schon ein bisschen genauer
ansehen was ich da was sagen kann ja am
besten ist sie dreht sich doch mal ein
bisschen um die hosen runter war ich
muss mir das jetzt schon unter die
teilweise 6000 6000 2 300 euro
sicherlich was soviel kann man das
irgendwie mit ratenzahlung ringe
das auf ratenzahlung gibt es jetzt die
möglichkeit das geld abzuarbeiten
abzuarbeiten ja willst du die op
wirklich ja natürlich also man jetzt
leben hängt daran ihr leben hängt dran
also abzuarbeiten da gibt es schon so
ein paar möglichkeiten
ach ja das ist wirklich willst
originaler porno dialogs auf dem level
von warum liegt hier stroh original ja
dann würde ich sagen machen wir das ich
kriege von den ordentlichen blowjob
[Musik]
youtube trend platz eins leute ja
das war's dann auf jeden fall komplett
ich kann das nicht weiter schauen wenn
ihr wollt heute sein kommentiert hier
unter dem video was da passiert ist
[Musik]
ich habe genug sind für heute platz eins
in youtube trends hat auf jeden fall mal
wieder nicht enttäuscht das war hoch
qualitative unterhaltung die definitiv
in der form perfekt für youtube geeignet
ist ein auftrag für ein junges publikum
da ist es einfach optimal wenn ein
schöner trocken junges mädchen belästigt
hatte ich drücke ihr die daumen ich
hoffe die folge ist gut für dich
ausgegangen ich bin raus leute